In Britain, British Ambassador to the US Kim Darroch announced his resignation,...
...saying it was "impossible" to continue in his role following the leak of diplomatic cables...
...featuring comments critical of US President Donald Trump.
In Russia, Russian police detained 7 Crimean Tatars on Moscow's Red Square...
...after dispersing a demonstration to draw attention...
...to alleged rights abuses on the Black Sea peninsula,...
...which Russia annexed from Ukraine five years ago.
Turkey has the largest number of refugees in the world with over 3.5 million Syrians,...
...but recent attacks on Syrian refugees and their businesses...
...has raised concerns about increased violence.
In Iran, President Rouhani said that Britain would face "repercussions"...
...over the seizure last week of an Iranian supertanker off Gibraltar.
Authorities detained the vessel on suspicion...
...that it was breaching European sanctions on oil shipments to Syria.
Finally, Monaco has become the first European country...
...able to provide nationwide 5G network access...
...based on technology from China's tech giant Huawei.
The company has signed 50 contracts worldwide for 5G network construction,...
...despite opposition from the US.